tips on managing school life
and a business i got a great question
from one of my youtube viewers love you
guys
aftermath who wrote in to say hello evan
i'm only 15 years old and i have started
my own media company events and
marketing
do you have any tips on how to balance
my school life and business
at the same time so it's a great
question and
i was a student entrepreneur you're
starting younger than me i started
really when i was in university
and it can be hard you know it can be
hard when you're trying to balance
running the business with all your
school load plus family obligations and
all that
and it can often seem i remember being
so frustrated especially when exam time
came around
and you know i really wanted to work on
my business and felt like there was just
too much happening in my life
so here are some tips okay here are some
tips for how you can manage
your school life and your business at
the same time number one
is do something every day do something
every single day for your business and
this this applies to anybody if you're
if you're starting a business if you're
doing it part-time you have you know a
full-time job you're starting on the
side
you have other commitments every day you
need to do something to grow your
business
even if you're you know you have an exam
the next day and you're cramming and
you're studying for it you still have to
find
20 minutes to do something for your
business it could be answering emails it
could be reaching out to somebody
whatever it is momentum has to keep
going
you cannot afford to take three weeks
off
and then just come back to the business
you lose too much in that process so
every day no matter how small do
something to grow your business
okay number two is get help
get people to help you out so i was
fortunate i had two business partners
in my business so when things got really
crazy at school
i still had my partners helping me out
but i also hired
people and the first guy i hired was for
one hour a day just an hour a day
doesn't cost a ton of money just to help
do some of the things that i didn't want
to do
anymore you know admin stuff that i
didn't want to take care of
so get some people to help you and this
is something you have to figure out as
you grow
right now you may just be a one-person
shop but you want to get your business
to the point where
you are not required in the day-to-day
running of your company
so it's great practice now to get
started to hire somebody
even for an hour a day you could be
somebody local or go to websites like
odesk.com which i'm a big fan of
and find people to help you out so it's
not just on you all the time
and then number three is incorporate
your school projects into your business
so one of my favorite things to do when
i was in university
i didn't realize this until my last year
was for the elective
projects that you take on
i always try to make it about my
business so
if i had a marketing class and we had to
do a marketing proposal
right or think of a new marketing idea i
would always bring
my company and say okay well here's a
project here's a company
here's a new business that's starting
let's do a marketing plan for this
business
whatever school project i had i always
tried to bring in
my company to be the topic you can't
always do it you know if you're doing a
project on ancient history
you're talking about egyptian times you
may not be able to incorporate your
business into that
but as much as possible and one thing
that i really love doing that really
helped my business out which i only
discovered at the end
i could create my own course and so in
university there's this option
and i don't know if there's an option in
your in your high school or not i
could make an elective course with the
professor as long as the professor said
i will mentor
this entrepreneur then you can create
your own course and so there's no exam
for it
uh you have to basically depends on what
you decide with your professor
but i was able to create a course around
building my business
and have a professor mentor me at the
same time so it provided a lot of great
things for me first of all it meant one
last class i had to study for
at school second of all i got guidance
from
the professor who was helping me out and
third of all i can use the school's
resources so my software actually sold
into universities
and i could go to the scientists at the
universities who would be my customers
and start talking to them about what i
was doing in my company and the
projects we're working on they're
talking to me because i'm a student at
the school of work on this school
project where they wouldn't talk to me
if it was from
this company and so i would investigate
i didn't
that that option wasn't promoted
anywhere i learned about it through a
friend who had done something similar
i don't know there's that option at your
high school but there may be an option
to work with one
professor or teacher i guess there and
create your own course around
your business somehow where they're
mentoring you and they give you a grade
at the end
so definitely investigate that option so
those are things that really helped me
so again just quick recap
do something every day get help and then
incorporate your classes into your
business as much as possible
that's my advice good luck i know it's
hard but keep working every day grinding
out
and believe those are watching like the
video give it a thumbs up below and let
me know what you think leave a comment
underneath you have a question
leave it below make your video response
just like i did for this one
and click on my face to subscribe to the
channel thank you so much and i'll see
you soon